pues de momento permanecen cerradas de
manera indefinida aunque el alcalde de
la ciudad bill de blasio ya ha dicho que
esto es una decisión temporal hasta que
la situación mejore sé lo que significa
hasta que las cifras de contagio estén
por debajo del 3% que es el máximo que
se había marcado la ciudad y el estado
de nueva york para tomar las decisiones
el cierre de colegio se da casi ocho
semanas después de que hayan reabierto
sus puertas y afectará a cerca de
300.000 alumnos que a partir de hoy como
decías comenzarán sus estudios de manera
remota desde el departamento de
educación de la ciudad han dicho que
están mejores preparados que la última
vez cuando ya hubo algunos problemas
técnicos y han comenzado a repartir
ordenadores y ipads entre los
estudiantes la polémica no se ha hecho
esperar y muchos padres que trabajan y
ya se habían organizado de cara a este
año pues no entiende nada se quejan
porque no entienden por qué las escuelas
públicas porque las privadas continuarán
abiertas han tenido que cerrar sus
puertas mientras que restaurantes y
gimnasios todavía están abiertos
porque preocupa mamen especialmente la
situación en estos momentos
si hablan pues sobre todo porque
recordemos que el nueva york fue el
epicentro inicial de esta pandemia y
parecía que se recuperaba mejor que el
resto de los estados pero en los últimos
días parece que los contagios se han
vuelto a disparar superándose 3% que
tanto preocupa y también han aumentado
las hospitalizaciones cuando tan sólo
quedan 7 días para que se celebre censo
en vivir así que el gobernador del
estado de nueva york andrew como está
haciendo mucho hincapié en estos últimos
días en que las familias traten de
viajar lo mínimo posible que esas
reuniones no superen las 10 personas y
que utilicen en todo momento la
mascarilla esto alan es un retroceso en
esta ciudad en un momento como decía que
está avanzando y además ya sabéis que la
semana pasada se impuso este toque de
queda a restaurantes y gimnasios que
tienen que cerrar sus puertas a las 10
de la noche y el gobernador andrew como
ya ha dicho que continúan que si
continúan aumentando los casos las
restricciones serán todavía más duras